blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
pakman now that we have
a larger sample size
we can talk about what is not just
something they'll try maybe
but what is clearly the new
electoral strategy to the extent that he
we can even call it a strategy
from the modern republican party and
that strategy or maybe the the right
word for it would be more of a tactic
is to call an election rigged to say
that there was fraud
before we actually even know the results
we started to see this with donald trump
months before the 2020 presidential
election and of course it has become
essentially the story told by
republicans about the 2020 election it
was rigged it was fraud mail-in ballots
massive dumps of ballots we need
forensic audits there were bamboo fibers
there was too much barbecue sauce on the
papers there was not enough okay maybe
not that last one but you get the point
this is the story it's the election
wasn't fair trump should be president
that's the story being told by the right
and then
we saw the exact same thing
with larry elder
in advance of this week's california
gubernatorial recall let's go i know
i've played these clips already this
week uh but let's go to larry elder
being asked by jacob sauberoff will you
commit to accepting the results of this
election this was the day before the
recall again whether or not you win or
lose will you accept the results of the
election tomorrow i think we all ought
to be looking at election integrity no
matter whether you're a democrat an
independent or republican let's all make
sure that the election is a fair
election so let's all work together no
matter what the results are to make sure
that the results are valid and
legitimate and everybody who voted
should have voted let's all do that
together is that a commitment to accept
the results of the election tomorrow
let's all do that together let's all
work together
on both sides of the aisle to make sure
that the election is a fair election we
know that's very familiar it's very
familiar for a reason and then also
here was donald trump doing the same
thing on newsmax an extra week earlier
as well got the recall election coming
up in less than a week it's actually
happening as we speak the polls appear
to show newsome look safer at this point
larry elder is the man uh that could
take it from him what do you think
happens in california
well it's probably rigged they're
sending out all ballots it's all uh the
the ballots are you know mail out
mail-in ballots in fact i guess you even
have a case where you can make your own
ballot when that happens uh
nobody's gonna win except uh these
democrats so you know look they're very
good the one thing they're good at is
rigging elections so i predict it's a
rigged election let's see how it turns
out so this is now a strategy and none
of this is surprising there is a very
good washington post article about this
former president trump trump's
false voter fraud claims found new life
in california's biggest election this
year
the top republicans seeking to replace
governor gavin newsom in tuesday's
recall declined before the election to
say whether he would accept the results
a website affiliated with his campaign
invites visitors to sign a petition to
stop the fraud of the california recall
election and a previous version of the
site published before the election took
place blamed voter fraud for newsom
being quote reinstated as governor now
it's funny to even say reinstated he was
never removed
the article goes on to explain of course
there is no evidence for these claims
which have nonetheless been amplified
repeatedly by trump but their arrival in
the country's largest blue state offered
proof of their currency within the
republican party where some leaders have
increasingly sought to undermine public
confidence in democratic victories
that's an understatement by baselessly
alleging that elections are vulnerable
to
manipulation
um it does mention with newsome
projected to defeat the recall elder
conceded the race early wednesday
morning telling his audience to be
gracious in defeat
but the campaign tactics leading up to
the vote including open threats to raise
doubts about the results in case of
defeat suggest the possibility of a new
normal where republicans challenge
election losses even in heavily
democratic states without proof of
serious fraud or rule breaking
this is going to be the strategy
now
none of it should surprise us
it is number one straight out of trump's
playbook elder is essentially a trump
clone agreeing with trump on just about
everything if a republican wins the
election then we can trust the results
everything is as it should be no fraud
took place
if they lose then it's rigged and this
is going to be i believe their mo from
here on out
and not only is this concerning
because it is the next step in
republicans completely abandoning trying
to win on issues
i'm not going to give you the whole
story that noam chomsky and i discussed
of how this came to be because it goes
all the way back to the civil rights
movement
and and that era but
recently at least as recent history is
concerned as far as recent history is
concerned
we saw
particularly in the obama era and
obviously when trump ran
trump pretended to be about policy when
he ran
although they were all completely
unrealistic policy promises based on
misstatements about the world right um a
completely bogus promise to build a wall
across the entire southern border with
mexico that mexico would pay for
based on lies about the immigration
situation so the the framework was lies
and the proposed solution was never
going to happen he was never going to
build that wall mexico was never going
to pay for it but it was like pretending
to be about policy to the 2020 election
not even pretending to be about policy
that's marjorie taylor greene that's
madison cawthorne that's lauren bobert
they don't even pretend to be about
policy and then the next step is despite
not actually
doing policy or
campaigning on policy
when you lose you say that it was rigged
this is very authoritarian it is very
authoritarian and it's a very dangerous
new status quo if that's indeed what is
what it's going to be and you know what
the signal was that they were going to
do it
in 2016 trump won electorally
and still didn't accept the results of
the popular vote remember he said
hillary clinton didn't even really win
the popular vote she won because of
millions of illegal immigrants that
voted and or you know people from
massachusetts were being bussed up to
new hampshire to vote of course ignoring
the fact that none of those
massachusetts people would be registered
to vote in new hampshire they wouldn't
be able to vote in new hampshire but
every election now is going to be
fraudulent
until and unless there start to be
consequences for telling that lie
time after time after time and um it is
i i don't think i have to explain this
to you but there's also the
it's not even a hypocrisy it's sort of
like a conflict between
they claim
that
i guess the democratic party although
think about the number of people that
would need to be involved they claim the
democratic party is smart enough
uh to
manufacture millions of fraudulent votes
and get away with it
but they don't actually put the votes in
places
where it would have a bigger effect on
the race like it just none of it makes
sense and with regard to trump there's
one other aspect to this
narcissists can't admit to being wrong
so when the polling data started to show
trump's going to lose elder is going to
lose
particularly with elder recently they
started the campaign well if they win
it's because they've stolen it if they
win it's because it's rigged
because they can't just say we just we
were just wrong
california didn't want to remove gavin
newsom we miscalculated we were wrong
they have to go to it was actually fraud
and then maybe the most insidious and
scary part
which maybe they're not competent enough
for
is that this could end up being part of
a cry-wolf strategy
claim that there's fraud when there
isn't in a whole bunch of races where
they lose
then they commit the fraud in some
future election
and then when democrats say guys there
was real fraud here
then they brush it off and they say guys
we everybody's sick of these claims of
fraud just accept that these are the
results i hope that that doesn't happen
because they're not organized enough to
do it but that's a scary aspect of this
as well
let's talk a little bit about another
hypocrisy
which is that on fox news they have had
all of these different news anchors
tucker carlson
laura ingraham and all of these you you
know the you know the crew
bemoaning
and denouncing joe biden's vaccine
requirements
for big businesses
as tyrannical
as authoritarian
as illegal as unconstitutional
uh despite not being any of those things
when fox news has had an actual stricter
policy
on masking on testing and on vaccines
which the white house is now praising
this this is actually uh unbelievable
the white house is now praising fox for
having a stricter version
of biden's vaccine or test mandate
despite bashing the policy on air
the white house praised one of its top
media critics fox news for announcing an
even stricter vaccine or test mandate
than the administration's new federal
policy for employers
fox announced tuesday it will soon roll
out daily covid testing for unvaccinated
employees remember biden's proposal
was
vaccinated or weekly testing fox is
going to do vaccinated or daily testing
if you've not revealed your vaccination
status to the company they've asked
employees to submit vaccination status
and revealed 90 percent of its employees
confirmed they had been immunized
against the virus think about that
if the country
was as vaccinated as fox news employees
things would be going way better right
now denmark which is 75 vaccinated which
is still almost 50 percent greater than
us
um denmark is essentially wide open with
declining cases
fox is 90 vaccinated
if the country was as vaccinated as fox
news which on air criticizes vaccine
requirements we would be in a really
good position right now um as the
article says last week biden announced
all employers with more than 100
employees must mandate vaccines or
weekly testing fox previously required
certain essential employees to undergo
regular testing the white house urged
fox to inform its audience about the
effectiveness of such policies white
house spokesperson said tuesday today's
news from fox follows a trend we're
seeing across the country vaccination
and testing requirements work we're glad
they've stepped up to protect their
workforce and strengthen the economy we
encourage them to convey to their
audience that these types of practices
will protect their employees communities
and the economy this is in addition to
fox's policy
that only vaccinated employees can
remove masks in some settings all
employees must be masked in confined
indoor settings think about that
biden rolls out a policy which is if you
have 100 employees
you've got a vaccinate or you've got a
test weekly no mandated masking for the
unvaccinated
foxes on on-air talent
goes on and says this is tyrannical this
is not freedom this is un-american this
must be stopped this could be against
the law
and yet behind the scenes
fox news has the same vaccinator test
requirement except at fox it's not a
weekly test it's a daily test if you're
unvaccinated and in addition to that in
some settings if you're unvaccinated you
have to keep wearing a mask it is much
stricter at fox news than what fox's own
on-air talent decries as tyrannical
government oppression
uh as outlined by joe biden in his
proposal so why hasn't tucker carlson
resigned to protest these dystopian
policies uh meanwhile he's on air saying
hey you know what we we've gotta we've
gotta investigate we've gotta fly to
trinidad to interview nicki minaj's
cousin's friend whose testicles swelled
after getting the evil vaccine and yet
he's part of a company with a stricter
requirement than what joe biden has laid
out and you know the reason why
it's all disingenuous garbage tucker
makes a ton of money at fox news it's
really that simple
but he makes the money at fox off of an
audience whose education and finances
are different than his
the messaging on his show isn't for
people like him for people in his tax
bracket with the amount of sort of
market power that he has
as a well-paid and and um uh
uh highly rated fox news host uh it's
for people who make a lot less money and
have a lot less market power in dealing
with their employers
who actually are at much greater risk if
they show up and they say what you guys
are doing is tyrannical tucker told me
on fox news so it's all a setup for
tucker's audience to just blame the left
blame the left for all of it uh and you
don't you know the all of the bad things
that are happening are because of
democrats and we should oppose all of it
even though tucker himself is implicitly
accepting it by continuing to work at
fox news under a stricter mandate than
that which joe biden proposed last week
so it's pathetic
and uh we will keep calling it out
but at the end of the day if people
don't realize that this is all a ruse
they are going to keep getting
bamboozled by it and saying no tucker
told me that this is tyrannical tucker
told me that this is bad
let me know your thoughts you can find
me on twitter at deepakman
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for if there's a full book you're
thinking about buying you can use
blinkist to get a sample first just
think how much you can enrich yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great stephen hawking this
is a book that i have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about 8 bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
remember that you can join the
discussion on the david pakman show
subreddit at davidpakman.com
reddit that's
r-e-d-d-i-t a few posts i spotted this
morning i want to bring to your
attention because i think they're
interesting uh our user nash t asks
what's going on with the matt gates
investigation has it all been swept
under the rug
writing i'm horrified that so much has
come out about gates and yet he's still
going about life business as usual i
understand high profile cases take time
but what exactly is the timeline here
this is exactly why
when back in the summer
all of the news articles were saying
investigation arrest may be imminent and
gates's partner in crime was confessing
and pointing the finger at gates this is
why i was saying i don't know that gates
gets indicted i don't know that gates
gets charged i don't know that gates
gets arrested
and why there was no particular reason
other than oftentimes these guys just
avoid consequences one way or the other
now we don't know the status of the
investigation i'm hopeful that it will
at some point uh lead to charges if that
is what is determined should happen on
the basis of the investigation but this
is exactly why i said let's take it a
step at a time
i'm wondering just as much as you are
what is going on with matt gates another
post is about the reduced price of at
home covid testing
remember last week joe biden announced
that the covid at home coveted tests
would be offered at cost
walmart has lowered the cost
to 14
for a two pack and as user bae photo
points out
if this is at cost
it will be too expensive for many and
that i think that that's absolutely
right i've said before
i think that at five dollars a test it
starts to become
i don't know about it appealing but
doable for people who say
might be having
people over for an indoor event and they
say hey you know what let's be extra
safe let's test everybody uh four
dollars a test
i do think that seven dollars a test is
probably still too high
and i don't know how much at-home
testing we're going to get voluntarily
um at that price
maybe the prices will continue to come
down but i think around the four dollar
a test mark is
what would make sense to me so far it
seems like it's not going to go below
seven at least in the immediate
another user asked does david think
teachers are the problem with the
education system in the u.s
writing does anyone else get the
impression david puts blame on teachers
and schools for some of the problems of
today's society i'm sure he doesn't
intend to but at times it sounds like
david is trashing education and teachers
he will say things like the us education
system is failing or schools don't teach
critical thinking anymore while that's
true
an uneducated listener might think david
is advocating for privatized education
or incentivized teacher pay
both of which have been studied
extensively and are terrible for schools
teachers and students uh no i i want to
be so
that that is not what i am saying when i
say we have a failing educational system
um i am talking about a combination of
misplaced priorities as a result of
often politicized school boards
that have been taken over by
right-wingers who don't want critical
think critical thinking taught or
philosophy or epistemology etc so so
that's often partisan school boards
and it's a funding issue where we always
have money for you know you know the
stuff right you know the drill we always
have money for bombs we always have
money for war but when it's education we
always have to be fighting for and
justifying every dollar so i'm not
blaming teachers i think 90 something
percent of teachers are doing the best
they can with the resources they have
and the curricula that they are in many
school districts
obligated to teach to and teach from i
am not blaming teachers i am not blaming
teachers glad for the opportunity to
clarify join the discussion at
davidpakman.com
reddit
um we have been covering this completely
outrageous
revelation
about mark milley the general having to
take preventive measures after
trump lost to joe biden in november of
2020 and after the trump riots because
millie was worried
that donald trump might consider
launching nukes including possibly
against china
trump wants millie charged with treason
as best levin writes in vanity fair for
making him look stupid a reaction
keeping in line with trump's famously
thick skin this is a very much worth
reading article
um
best writing
sometimes something you may have gleaned
is trump doesn't take criticism
constructive real or imagined very well
one major example of his paper-thin skin
is his reaction to the american people
denying him a second term in office
which resulted in him inciting a violent
mob to attack the us capital
naturally it is in no way surprising his
reaction to the news that mark milley
took steps to stop him from starting a
war with china and a nuclear war with
any number of countries was
characteristic of trump i.e bat s crazy
with a string of terrifying run-on
sentences to boot
donald trump put out a statement in
response to this
saying if the story of dumbass general
mark milley the same failed leader who
engineered the worst withdrawal from a
country afghanistan and u.s history
remember that was trump's withdrawal
leaving behind many dead and wounded
soldiers many american citizens and 85
billion dollars worth of the newest and
most sophisticated military equipment in
the world and our country's reputation
is true
then i assume he would be tried for
treason
and that he would have been dealing with
his chinese counterpart behind the
president's back and telling china he
would be giving them notification of an
attack
can't do that
trump going on to say the good news is
the story is fake news concocted by a
weak and ineffective general together
with two authors who i refuse to give an
interview to because they write fiction
this is a run-on sentence string of
insanity and here was trump as a
reminder on newsmax making similar
claims this is a former president folks
so first of all if it is actually true
which is hard to believe
that he would have called
china and done these things and was
willing to advise them of an attack or
in advance of an attack that's treason
and i would think i've had so many calls
today saying that's treason number one
number two it's totally ridiculous i
never thought of it you were there you
were you knew what was happening in the
white house you had plenty of friends
you never heard the word china mentioned
in a thing like this you heard a lot of
anger so remember he's referring of
course to sean spicer saying you were at
the white house actually spicer was long
gone by the time all of this stuff was
going on that's of no meaning but
multiple times now trump says
treason he wants the general charged
with treason
the correct assessment of this is
even if ultimately if millie let's
imagine trump tried to launch nukes
if initially millie tried to prevent
that in some way
trump could fire millie
and eventually replace him with someone
who would allow the nukes to be fired
that's the reality ultimately millie
could not have actually prevented this
but millie out of a responsibility to
the united states and the world
identified such an unusual danger
to the united states and the world in
trump in these deranged final 13 days
right we're talking about the period
between january 8
when millie had this meeting with other
military officials and trump leaving
office that's the period we're talking
about
that millie had to do something
completely different than what former
chairman of the joint chiefs have had to
do that's the real story and of course
there is no treason here trump is
completely unhinged it shouldn't
surprise us and it's another reminder of
we should be glad as disastrous as the
presidency was
we should be glad that it wasn't even
worse given what trump's
tendencies were as further revealed
that's the takeaway not that mark milley
is a traitor quite the opposite in fact
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
it's great to be joined today by
professor michael sandell professor of
political philosophy at harvard
university and also author of the
now in paperback book the tyranny of
merit can we find the common good it's
so great to have you on i appreciate
your time
good to be with you david so
to maybe start talking a little bit
about the the the topic of of merit
there's often sort of like two layers to
this discussion and one is a focus on an
argument as to whether we or a
particular country or society or economy
uh have a real meritocracy that's one
piece of the conversation the second
part which is less discussed but
arguably just as important if we really
did have a pure meritocracy would that
actually be a good thing what would be
the concerns what would be the problems
if it was really that everybody got what
they quote deserved from whatever sort
of perspective we want to approach that
question so
can can we maybe start with how we can
combine these two questions and enter
the kind of philosophy that that you lay
out in the book
yes and i do address both questions and
you're right to distinguish them it's
very important
the first problem with meritocracy is
that we don't live up to the
meritocratic principles we profess
in ivy league universities for example
there are more students from the top one
percent
than there are from students in families
in the bottom half of the income scale
combined
if you if you come from an affluent
family
top
uh the top quarter
you're
70 of the students who attend the
hundred
selected 100 plus most selective
colleges and universities seventy
percent
come from the top quartile well off
families
and do you know how many come from the
from the bottom quartile from low income
families
it must be incredibly small
it's three percent right and now so we
don't live up to the meritocratic
principles we profess it isn't true as
the slogan we hear from politicians
tells us
that you can make it if you try
that everyone really has an equal chance
to succeed so that's one problem with
meritocracy we we haven't realized it we
don't chances are not truly equal
but there's a deeper problem
which is that the ideal is flawed
and this is really the heart of my
argument in the tyranny of merit
meritocracy has a dark side
and the dark side is that it is
corrosive of the common good and let me
see if i can explain why because this is
a counter-intuitive idea we normally
think that if only we could perfect the
meritocracy
then we would have a just society right
but think about it
if it were really true
that everyone's place in society
and in the income scale
were the result of their own doing
such that they could say i've earned it
i deserve my place
then
those who landed on top
would believe their success was their
own doing the measure of their merit
and they would look upon those who
struggle
as deserving their fate as well
in fact the person who coined the term
meritocracy he was a british sociologist
michael young in 1958
he coined it the rise of the meritocracy
was his book
as a dystopian scenario because he
glimpsed this
he glimpsed the hubris
that a meritocracy
generates among the successful
and the humiliation
and resentment
it generates among those left behind now
you asked me david how do i bring these
two arguments together in the book
we've got in a way the worst of both
worlds
we don't have a true meritocracy because
opportunities are not truly equal
and yet
those who've landed on top especially in
recent decades
have come to believe
that their success is their own doing
and that they therefore deserve
the full measure of the benefits that a
market society showers upon them so we
have the hubris among the successful
we have the humiliation and the brewing
resentment understandable resentment
among those who struggle
even without
a genuine meritocracy and and i think
that the anger and resentment
among many working people
that elites meritocratic elites
credentialed at least looked down on
them
that set of resentments and anger those
grievances
have gave rise to trump to donald trump
and they persist because the democratic
party really has become
the party
of meritocratic credentialed elites
and has lost contact with
the working class
which once constituted its space going
back to the new deal
that's that's very interesting and
there's a lot of aspects there that that
we could dig more into
for because you mentioned political
party it seems that one of the i don't
even know that it's a side effect i mean
it's really a direct consequence of the
idea that everybody sort of has what
they've earned and what they've deserved
with equal opportunity it seems like
politically it's a recipe to justify
doing very little to help those whose
position is is lesser or less good
because after all it's a direct result
merely of their actions that they are
there and in fact it's this isn't
theoretical
some of the primary arguments made to
cut welfare programs uh against the
so-called enhanced unemployment during
the pandemic that we've seen against all
of these things is that
it it's some form of laziness or simply
choosing one's circumstances why would
we reward people for that it has a very
direct line to policy
it does and we hear this argument all
the time
in debates about welfare and other forms
of income support
what's interesting
is the way
troubling but also important to come to
terms with the way the democratic party
has migrated from being
a party that speaks
for the middle class and the working
class against the privilege
to being really the embodiment of
credent well-credentialed elites and the
professional classes and this happened
really over the last four decades
as the democratic party along with
republicans embraced
a kind of market driven finance driven
version of globalization
and education admonishing people to
improve themselves through higher
education that's been a big part of the
message especially of the democratic
party in the face of rising inequality
and wage stagnation
and job loss
over the last four decades
what we've heard from politicians
mainstream politicians
is not
an attempt to deal directly with
inequalities of income and wealth and
power
they've offered a kind of meritocratic
workaround
they've they've offered individual
upward mobility through higher education
if you want to compete and win in the
global economy
go to college what you earn
will depend on what you learn that was
bill clinton you can make it if you try
that was barack obama
but what they missed now it seems
inspiring to encourage everybody to go
to college or university
and increasing access broadening access
to higher education that's a good thing
i'd be the last person to argue against
that
but as a response or as the primary
response
to the rising inequality
of the globalization decades
and as a response
to the wage stagnation and job losses
experienced by many working people
that is a pale
offer
beca because those of us it contains an
implicit insult if you think about it
right
improve your condition
you will surmount wage stagnation and
job loss and inequality
uh the problem is that you aren't well
enough educated the problem is not that
we embraced policies that created this
widening gap it's that you are not well
enough educated so that was the insult
implicit in the seemingly inspiring uh
admonition
to go get a better education
and the result was
um
rising resentment among people who felt
that their concerns were not being taken
seriously yeah that's there's a couple
of interesting things there i mean so
we've seen a story that i first remember
hearing it um i think it was with rick
the senator from pennsylvania rick
santorum about maybe 20 years ago where
he started to say
uh you know we're
education is liberal indoctrination
we're never going to have those people
on our side because these mechanisms of
colleges and universities they're just
going to indoctrinate people into
left-wing sort of points of view
the left on the other hand has talked
about
let's get people college educations
let's look at free college let's look at
making it cheaper more accessible
etcetera and there's a couple of effects
of that one is that it's saying if and
until you do that you will be less than
the people that have done that but also
isn't there some degree to which if
everybody went ahead and did that
doesn't it sort of zero out and not even
actually solve the problems of
inequality that it claims to resolve
you're right it does not solve the
problem of inequality i think it's
desirable for its own sake
to make a college free and accept or at
least as accessible as possible yes the
people from every background that's a
good in and of itself
and i'm all in favor of it
but the question is whether that is an
adequate response
to the inequality and wage stagnation of
recent decades right and i say it isn't
um first of all those of us who spend
our days in the company of credential of
the credentialed
can easily forget
a simple fact
most americans do not have a four-year
college degree
nearly two-thirds do not right so it's
folly
to
create an economy
that sets us unnecessary condition
of dignified work in a decent life
a college degree that most people don't
have
it also this way of thinking
is too too blinker to narrow an approach
to inequality
because it leaves in place the steep
hierarchy of prestige and esteem
associated with people
who
who are well credentialed right and it
implicitly disparages those who aren't
and this is embodied in in policy and in
funding
an economist at the brookings institute
figured uh institution figured out that
we spend
uh about
164 billion dollars a year helping
people go to college
and how much do we spend
supporting people who go in for
vocational and technical training
and community colleges
at the federal level about 1 billion 162
to 1. now
there is there's something wrong with
that
mode of funding
for those forms of learning
including community colleges and
technical and vocational training
that many
people rely on to prepare themselves for
the world work but this this imbalance
reflects this broader
skewing of our values
in the direction of valorizing people
who are well credentialed
and implicitly disparaging those
who have not been to university and this
is showing up in the way people are
voting
trump managed to tap into
the grievance
against elites that many working people
felt
and
you can look at the voting behavior in
the last few decades
as a college the college-educated vote
has gone increasingly for democrats
and the vote among those who haven't
been to college goes increasingly for
republicans
and especially
republicans like trump of an
authoritarian populist bent who channel
the anger and the sense of grievance and
what's interesting is a similar pattern
is unfolding in britain and in france
and in other countries that have
embraced globalization
emphasize the meritocratic uh solution
to inequality
and have alienated center-left parties
now there's there are some who would
look at that phenomenon that you
identify of the college educated voter
voting more for democrats voting more
for center-left and left-wing parties in
the uk and say well this is there's a
very simple intuitive explanation for
that as you become more educated and you
learn more about the world
you realize it's better for everybody
it's better for the country to vote for
these people you're doing an altruistic
thing you're doing a rational thing and
we're all better off for it
right
and that in itself i think is a
hubristic
analysis of the situation because in
fact
the policies the kind of finance driven
globalization or neoliberal
policies
embraced by
center right at center left parties
really center left and center right but
politically the toll has been taken upon
the democratic party in the u.s the
labor party in britain the socialist
party in france
these policies
have failed
and the 2008 financial crisis was the
most dramatic illustration of how a kind
of finance driven globalization project
fails
the recession that followed
which fell very heavily
on low and middle income
americans
demonstrate demonstrated further the
failure and then to add insult to injury
is the meritocratic uh attempt to say
that the solution to to inequality and
wage stagnation
is not to reconsider the policies that
we
promoted and enacted for 30 or 40 years
it's simply for you to improve
yourselves there's something deeply
disparaging about that so i think that
what i'm proposing for the democratic
party is a shift to focus less on arming
people for meritocratic competition and
to focus more on the dignity of work to
ask what would it take to make life
better
for everyone regardless of of the
university credentials they may have and
we we could explore and there will be
debates about what counts what policies
actually support
and affirm the dignity of work but i
think that should be the starting point
last thing i want to touch on are there
societies that we can look at either
today or historically that have had
maybe what we would call a more balanced
or productive or rational view on the
kind of interaction between merit and
equality that might be interesting as a
model in some sense
well in some ways and this is not to uh
engage in golden age nostalgia but
the political coalitions that formed uh
during the time of fdr in the new deal
were an example of coalitions that did
not depend
on admonishing working people to improve
themselves but instead ask how can we
structurally reform the economy
to
strengthen
collective bargaining to strengthen
unions to give working people more of a
voice more of a say as well as to to be
able to negotiate better working
conditions i think today
in some ways
uh biden
has begun to depart from
the meritocratic technocratic neoliberal
orientation of his predecessors and it's
interesting to notice
that
joe biden was the first democratic
nominee in 36 years
without an ivy league degree this may
have opened him at least a little
to a broader horizon he speaks more
actually about the dignity of work than
he does about meritocratic striving in
meritocratic competition there's also an
interesting political figure now you've
been looked at the german elections the
social democratic
candidate olaf schultz
has been trying to make this shift as
well to focus he's actually offered a
critique
of the single-minded focus on merit and
has emphasized instead notions of
respect and the dignity of work
and i think that this is a more
promising direction for the democratic
party and for center-left parties
generally
i could not uh could not agree more and
uh much of what we've been talking about
today
uh is in the just out in paperback book
the tyranny of merit can we find the
common good we've been speaking with the
book's author professor michael sandell
from harvard university so appreciate
your time and your insights today
thank you david
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpakmanshow
it's quite remarkable that in a short 48
hours this entire nicki minaj swollen
testicle uh trinidad and tobago story
has gone from something i didn't think i
would cover at all to something i ended
up covering yesterday because of how it
suddenly pulled in fox news propagandist
tucker carlson to something that today
we're following up on and it has
actually reached the health ministry of
trinidad and tobago so let's just go
through the entire backstory on this uh
the way that this all started is that uh
pop star nicki minaj tweeted a couple of
days ago quote
my cousin in trinidad won't get the
vaccine because his friend got it and
became impotent
his testicle testicles became swollen
his friend was weeks away from getting
married now the girl called off the
wedding it's kind of weird it'd be like
why that's like if someone gets
appendicitis do you call off the wedding
so just pray on it and make sure you're
comfortable with your decision and not
bullied and of course so many people
came forward and said that's not
actually a vaccine side effect just
because something happened after the
vaccine if it did doesn't mean it was
caused by the vaccine
my instinct was maybe maybe the
testicular swelling is an std from an
affair and that's why the wedding was
cancelled i even tweeted much to the
delight of many in my audience back to
nikki nikki is it maybe possible the
swollen apple bags were an std from
cheating and that's why the wedding was
called off
tucker carlson then got subsequently
involved and said we want to interview
this individual we want to talk to this
individual
who um supposedly had these swollen
testicles
this has now gone all the way up to the
health minister of trinidad and tobago
who explains we had to wait a little bit
before responding because we needed to
see what was this reported the
population is low enough there that this
would be something they would have a
record of uh he says there is no such
reported case let's take a listen one of
the reasons we could not respond
yesterday
in real time to mr minaj
is that we had to check
and make sure
that what she was claiming was either
true or false
we did we
unfortunately we wasted so much time
yesterday running down this false claim
this guy's disgusted which i love he
should be
it is
as far as we know at this point in time
there has been no such reported either
side effect or adverse event
and what was sad about this
is that
it wasted our time yesterday
trying to track down because we take all
these claims seriously right whether
it's on social media or mainstream media
as we stand now
there is absolutely no reported
such
side effect
or adverse event
of testicular swelling in trinidad or
idea see dr hangs anywhere else
none that we know of anywhere else in
the world okay so of course if you're
committed to this story you would say
well
a lot of people don't report their side
effects uh
i had arm pain or i had a headache i
never reported it
um
and of course if you want to be
endlessly skeptical you can you can
continue to be but that is the statement
from the health minister in trinidad and
tobago so what's the real takeaway here
the takeaway here
is that
we're working so hard to get people
vaccinated and to disseminate truth and
empiricism and and to make sure that
what's being said is backed up by data
and science
and someone like nicki minaj
who's in a position with so much
prominence nearly 200 million followers
across social media etc
with just one tweet could theoretically
dissuade i don't know if i want to say
tens of thousands like of the 200
million followers how many are currently
unvaccinated who have access et cetera
right
maybe she's dissuading tens of thousands
of people from vaccination
maybe hundreds of thousands
is it possible that it's in the millions
i don't know
but it can then take weeks to undo the
skepticism that's caused by just one
statement like that and that's why this
is so disturbing um if this individual
eventually comes forward
tucker carlson goes down to port of
spain and interviews the guy the way he
said he wanted to do okay we'll follow
up on it but let's hope that this is the
end of the nicki minaj swollen testicle
story
hey this is a wild wild story
yesterday trump crony who was convicted
and then pardoned actually by donald
trump roger stone
was served
lawsuit papers
while on the air this is a really really
wild situation roger stone served
lawsuit papers during a live radio
interview
notorious republican dirty trickster and
trump advisor stone had a radio
interview interrupted by a process
server audio was posted to twitter by
former federal prosecutor ron
phillipkowski
um we're going to take a look at that
video
while roger stone was live on air this
morning with realtalk933 st louis doing
an interview about 2024 he got served a
process server served by a process
server with the january sixth lawsuit
this is really something else take a
listen let me ask you you know you
you've said before that trump should run
again but i think lately you said it's
imperative he run in 2024 is that right
yeah i've kind of there's been an
evolution in my viewpoint um i really
you know politics three and a half years
is a lifetime
uh to say the least
and
okay so now it starts to get he starts
to get distracted you can tell
something's going on and i really did
not know
um
if
hold on a second i have a
server at my front door about to serve
me in the latest lawsuit i i'm going to
take this live on your radio on your
radar holy smokes
wow good morning sir how are you
terrific you know what i have yes of
course i'll be happy to accept your
papers
oh yes a civil court in the district of
columbia
ah yes
it's still a fraud doesn't matter thank
you sir appreciate it
all right i've just been served in the
this is a big big stack of papers which
is good because we're out of toilet
paper today
quite a funny guy huh oh my gosh oh my
roger
oh my god uh you know it's like i said
it's lawfare it's harassment
yeah so
this is a civil suit um maybe it'll get
some money out of roger stone but i have
to tell you
this guy has really shown over the last
few years he is a slippery guy
and he ends up somehow wiggling out of
every problem
uh remember when i interviewed him a few
years ago he said i'm never going to be
charged no way of course he was
ultimately charged he was convicted and
subsequently pardoned by donald trump i
mean the guy really is like a parasite
on the political system and it's a civil
suit maybe this will lead to some
financial consequences for him but quite
frankly i'm feeling pretty done
imagining that roger stone is ever
really going to face consequences and
there's sort of a two there's two
stories there
one is how have so many morally bankrupt
and despicable people
how have they become so powerful and
prominent insiders to the american
political system that's one question and
there are many answers to that including
that the system itself attracts these
folks by its very nature there's a
systemic structural answer to that
question but then the second part of it
is
by that very same nature of attracting
those people and putting them into
positions of power
many of them end up unscathed
on the basis of the things that they do
in carrying out
uh their henchmen activities within that
very same political system so it very
interesting to hear no doubt roger stone
served while on the air
but i i am sort of beyond imagining that
this guy is going to really face serious
consequences
hey this is a very strange voicemail
that i received you guys remember from
last week we had this
coughing uh woman at a nebraska grocery
store who was uh basically weaponizing
coughing
and she was ultimately after being
caught on a viral video coughing on
shoppers at a nebraska grocery store she
was fired by her then employer sap the
software company it's a business process
software company i got a voicemail
yesterday at 219 to david p or actually
i guess it came in this morning
from a woman defending the coughing
anti-mask woman i i did even for our
audience i never thought we would get
this but we did take a listen
mr pac-man did you bother to stop to
think that one you do not have a medical
degree
two you are not a state licensed
physician three you do not know the
whole entire
medical background as a patient
especially for that woman that you read
a video about anti-mass coughing woman
has yes that's true i'm not a doctor and
i don't have
the weaponized coffers medical history
so far you're right man
did your mother decide to think that
maybe she had copd
and that maybe she had all her
vaccinations
okay
she may have copd and she may be
vaccinated but she was weaponizing her
cough against people so it what does it
matter like me
did you bother to think about that at
all
that pulmonologists are promenades who
are medically licensed state medically
licensed physicians have that
determination to make that determination
medical evaluation if whether or not we
can wear a mask at all or not
the woman herself didn't say
i have a condition and that's why i'm
not wearing a mask in fact she said the
opposite she said
i'm not sick and you're not sick so
nobody needs masks and then she
deliberately coughed on shoppers this is
a delusional reaction to that video i
did not appreciate that video at all
regarding of that woman
seems like you misunderstood it was not
one of them asked because people that do
have copd
cardio obstructive pulmonary disease
that we do cause even though we had our
vaccinations everything else but even in
the video the woman says she has
allergies so you're i mean this is
you're wrong on every count the woman
said there is no medical reason why
she's for which she's not wearing a mask
the woman said
her coughing was allergies which was
obviously a lie and she was deliberately
coughing so i i'm shocked anyone would
defend that woman
but somebody did and they're in my
audience that's something to think about
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we're going to talk about the new
push by joe biden and the uk to help
australia get nuclear submarines
presumably for positioning against china
very interesting geopolitical story we
will also talk about a push by lawmakers
to get facebook to abandon instagram for
kids saying there are mental health
concerns with that that proposal and
lastly the justice department the biden
justice department headed up by merrick
garland is looking for an emergency
order to block the new oppressive texas
abortion law all of those stories and
more we will discuss on today's bonus
check
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman